we as new senior national security
analysts Fran Townsend served 13 years
in the Justice Department she was
homeland security adviser to President
George W Bush Fran good morning morning
John in terms of what the FBI is saying
here at one point there were questions
about whether sources and methods and
intelligence would be revealed and then
the FBI said after looking at the memo
the FBI said we have grave concerns
about material emissions of facts so is
the FBI saying that sources and methods
are in danger or just that the memo has
bad information in it I think it's both
I think what they're saying is both they
are concerned about sources and methods
part of that John is for them to rebut
what is the contents of the núñez memo
would require them to reveal sources and
methods so they're really they're sort
of their hands are tied and this is part
of the difficulty of this I think we
have to remember the Nunez memo is an
advocacy piece it's not a fact piece
this is chairman Nunez --is summary of
what he believes the abuses are but it's
for that reason it's one-sided I my
understanding from sources inside the
FBI is that director ray is prepared to
rebut if the White House decides to
release the Munez memo director Ray is
prepared to issue a rebuttal and so the
question is what will that contain does
that tee up a real confrontation between
the White House and the FPL that's
extraordinary that the current if you
what you're reporting is that the FBI
director may release an alternative memo
why would they want to do that what's
the importance of that well look they're
under fire and in fairness to the FBI I
mean what they're they feel under siege
there this is the tearing down of a
respected institution look institutions
are made of people right and people make
mistakes I'm not suggesting that they've
never made a mistake but understand what
this process is I ran this unit in the
Justice Department that got this visor
warrants there's multiple internal
reviews in the FBI there's a legal
review at the Justice Department it goes
to the Attorney General or in this case
the deputy who reviews it and then it
goes to an independent federal judge who
looks at it know FISA warrant relies on
a single piece of evidence so if the
allegation from Chairman Nunez is that
they relied solely on the steeled
dossier that's not possible it never
happens there would have been multiple
pieces of evidence in other words one
partisan or bad-apple inside that cannot
make a FISA warrants become that's a
wreck
surveillance that's exactly right Nora
it's just it doesn't work that way and I
think you know look if chairman Nunez
wants to have his memo released I don't
understand if he's confident in it why
wouldn't you release Adam Schiff the
Democrats response to that and have it
all out there then well the White House
press secretary Sarah Sanders has said
that the president has confidence in the
FBI director and the rank and file but
you know when you're a little kid and
your mom says actions speak louder than
words do the president's actions tell a
different story about the confidence he
has in the FBI well my mother used to
say Gail you know I don't like the act
but I love the person so I mean it's
possible that the president respects
chris ray the director of the FBI but
disagrees with some of the actions there
but I do think that this this acrimony
this public acrimony really only
benefits our enemies and adversaries and
so the president the White House and the
FBI have to gonna they're gonna have to
find a path forward where they can work
together and it's not clear right now
that they're doing that Brian can you
give us a little context on McCabe
there's the these reports that they
delayed after seeing their a new batch
of Hillary Clinton emails that they
delayed before announcing it to Congress
I've been told it was Department of
Justice procedure FBI procedure to be
sensitive about things that might
actually affect the outcome of an
election so if there was a delay is that
something sinister or is that just the
normal prudence and caution they would
have taken well you're quite right John
there is Justice Department internal
guidelines not to take public action
that may affect the outcome of an
election when you get close but my
understanding here from sources inside
the FBI was initially they believed
there might have been as many as 600,000
emails some of which may have been
classified and there would have had to
have been an entire process to review
that we know now there weren't that many
but you could understand them treading
pretty cautiously and legally frankly in
did they need to get a warrant
additional search warrants to touch that
those emails and review them were they
classified and so look I think we
shouldn't attribute malice where it
might have just been bureaucratic
caution yes there was we always hear
about public fatigue on this but this is
very important what is nothing and we
need to get to the bottom of it
absolutely Thank You Fran Fran always
good to have you here thank you so much